let's have a look in a little more
detail the context behind that startling
inflation figure of 11.1 this is what it
looks like in historical context we have
to go way back to 1981 since we had
prices rising this fast you can see the
steepling increase this year as a result
following the war in Ukraine and then
this jump in the month one full
percentage point in October largely
driven by Energy prices it's this is the
contributors to that inflation figure
and you can see housing including energy
at the top there 0.9 percentage points
almost all of it that's because the
price cap capped back in April gave way
to a new figure capped This Time by the
government in October and it fed through
into consumer bills so that's why the
numbers jumped so much food also an
important driver of costs Rising you can
see there's a negative impact actually
on cost of Transport at the bottom there
that includes petrol and diesel prices
are actually falling back in the period
that's been measured so of course there
On The Rise now so that respite won't
last very long food inflation I
mentioned it it has been really really
painful for consumers 16.4 year on year
to October that's how much more a basket
of shopping is costing see the rise here
it coincides with the general inflation
figure and since the war in Ukraine
began feed fuel fertilizer all the
components of Agriculture all involve
energy all getting more expensive and
we're feeling it at the checkout now
this inflation does not fall evenly
across income groups this is the
population split up into deciles with
the richest in the country at this end
back to the poorest and look at the real
inflation figure for the very poorest 12
and a half percent 11.9 12 and a half
percent for the poorest third of the
population compare that to real
inflation for the richest under 10 for
the very richest that's because the poor
spend more of their income on food and
fuel than the riches so they are feeling
this inflation harder than anyone now
what does this mean for what the bank of
England is going to do for interest
rates well this shows what the bank's
done the last eight meetings of the
monetary policy committee up up up up up
up up up up up up we had 0.75 percentage
Point increase at the meeting earlier
this month taking interest rates to
three percent as an expectation there'll
be another rise when they meet next
month and this figure which the bank
does think may be the peak means another
hike perhaps after Christmas in February
is likely so while this may be the peak
of inflation we've seen today the pain
for households is not over